Most people, they approach high-stakes
conversations like they're playing a
game of checkers. One move at a time,
they say what comes to mind and then
they just hope for the best. But great
communicators, they're playing a game of
chess. They're 10 steps ahead. They've
already planned the conversation in
advance, where it can go wrong, and how
to course correct when it does go wrong.
I've spent over the last 15 years
coaching communication to Fortune 500
companies, and the single biggest
difference that I've noticed between
people who thrive under pressure and
people who don't is actually not how
smart they are. It's about how they
prepare for those types of
conversations. We're going to cover two
things: everything before the
conversation starts, pre-game. [music]
This is how you prepare for a
high-stakes conversation. And then
everything that happens during the
conversation, I call this game time.
This is how to navigate the conversation
and steer it in the direction you want.
By the end of this video, you'll know
how to [music] walk into any
high-pressure conversation, like a
salary negotiation, a difficult client,
or a tough conversation with your boss,
and you're going to be able to leave
with the outcome you want. You see,
there are four pathways a conversation
could have. The first one is
lose-lose. [music]
This is where no one gets what they
want. Then there is win-lose. This is
where you get what you want and the
other person doesn't. By the way, this
is how people think conversations should
be. And then [music] there is win-win.
Both parties walk away feeling like they
got what they wanted. And the fourth is
actually a little bit cheeky because the
fourth is lose-win.
I'll explain why this is cheeky later.
Understanding that these four pathways
exist will help you in the pre-game
phase. Because now you can see any
conversation as a set of four possible
outcomes you can deliberately steer it
towards, instead of something you just
react to in the moment. Like I said
earlier, most people try to create a
win-lose scenario. They think, "How do I
get what I want here?" Let me share with
you a story that demonstrates this. My
best friend Ali went to Harvard in
America to do one of the top negotiation
programs in the world. They had about 30
students in the class and they split
them into groups of two. One person was
selling a product and the other person
had to negotiate. So Ali immediately
thought to himself, "If I'm the person
buying the product, my goal is to get
the product for the lowest price
possible." So he negotiated hard. He's
got his partner down 75%. He comes back
to the room with a massive smile on his
face because he thinks he's done it. But
then the professor looked at him and
basically said, "You actually did really
bad, Ali." And Ali was shocked thinking,
"What the hell?" The professor looked at
him and said, "The point of a
negotiation isn't to destroy the other
person and their profit margins. It
isn't to make the other person lose. A
great negotiation is when both people
walk away feeling like they've won."
And that lesson is such an important one
because Ali got the best numbers in the
room, but his partner hated him for it
by the end of the process. And this is
why I'm telling you that story. The
foundational framework for any
high-stakes conversation has to be
win-win. Whether you're asking for a pay
rise, whether you're speaking to a
difficult client, whether you're trying
to get an idea across to your boss, if
the whole mindset is win-lose, then it
comes across as selfish. [music] And
that shows up in your voice, your body
language, and your energy. Whereas when
your mindset is win-win, you stop trying
to corner the other person. Instead, you
start trying to understand what they
need and how they can win. People can
feel this and I promise you that you
will get more of what you want out of
this life by having this as a default
mindset.
>> [music]
>> And trust me, the goodwill from living
this way, it compounds over time. Once
you get that right, the next thing you
need, that's the pre-game. This is where
most people go wrong because they think
preparation means scripting the whole
conversation out in their own head. They
think, "What am I going to say if they
say this? What exact line am I going to
use? How do I phrase this perfectly?"
The issue with that approach is the
moment the conversation moves in a
direction you didn't anticipate, the
script collapses and now you're stuck
trying to think and speak at the same
time. What you actually want before a
high-stakes conversation is a high-level
map. And this map does not need to be
hyper-specific. You're not trying to
predict every single turn in the road.
You just want to be moving in the right
direction. So before any high-stakes or
high-pressure conversation, there are
three things I want clarity on. Number
one, what is the outcome I want?
Clarifying your non-negotiable outcome
gives you a clear destination, so you
can stay flexible with the path while
still knowing where to push and when to
trade and actually when to walk away.
The second question is, what's the
outcome they want? This is where we
apply the win-win lens. This forces you
to step out of your own head and get
really specific about what's in it for
them, their incentives, and what gets
them excited. And number three, what are
the sensitive and difficult parts of
this conversation?
Parts of the conversation where it could
go sideways, and how would you navigate
it if you happen to get to those places
in the conversation? By naming the
likely friction points in advance, you
can prepare cleaner explanations,
alternative paths, or questions for each
one, which makes you much much harder to
rattle in the moment. Let me show you
exactly what I mean by what I just said.
One of our dream clients reached out to
us, Disney. Now, I watch Disney with my
kids all the time. The Lion King, I
reckon I've watched that like a thousand
times. So just getting the opportunity
to work with one of the most biggest
brands in the world felt amazing. But
here's where the pressure came in. They
wanted a small, highly tailored session
for about 30 of their leaders. And
that's great for them, but from our side
of the business, those boutique sessions
are hard because we coach hundreds and
sometimes a thousands of people every
single cohort we teach. So going into
that call, I was stuck between a rock
and a hard place. I didn't want to lose
the opportunity, but at the same time, I
didn't want to do something that would
negatively impact the scalability of our
business. So, beforehand, I got really
clear on what they wanted. They wanted a
specialized coaching session for their
team. And I got really clear on what I
wanted. To be able to work with one of
the biggest brands in the world and to
be able to do so in a way that scales,
meaning bigger cohorts, more [music]
impact. And I got extremely clear on
where the conversation could go
sideways. Number one, I put the 30
Disney leaders into my public class
that's not tailored to them at all.
They'll hate that. Number two, I agree
on these smaller classes and it sets a
precedent for how we work together in
the future that I can't sustain. Or
three, they might not end up working
with me because I'm too inflexible. And
that was the map. It wasn't some hyper
specific script. It was a clear
understanding of the lay of the land.
And during the conversation, I led with
what they needed. I said, "Hey, look, I
completely get why you want a small
tailored class. And if I were in your
shoes, I'd want the same thing." But I
also named what I needed. I said, "We
normally work with much larger cohorts.
However, I would really love to work
with you. This isn't something I would
normally do, but we're happy to work on
a solution together with you. I'll run
this first cohort as a small group of
30. And I'm going to show you that
through that experience how we don't
lose any impact with scale because we'll
be using breakout rooms so that even if
we had 500 people on the call in the
training, every single time I teach the
leaders a new concept, we'll break them
into smaller breakout rooms and in
groups of three so they can apply the
things they learn in the small groups so
it doesn't lose its intimacy. But I'll
run it with a small group first to prove
to you that this is possible. And if I
can do this, would you be open to us
scaling what we do together? So, on the
surface, after I said that, it seems
like it was a lose-win situation where I
lost and I had to compromise. But in
actual reality, because I was prepared
for the conversation by looking at what
they wanted, looking at what I wanted,
and looking for the difficult parts of
the conversation, I was able to be
prepared and be flexible to come up with
the solution that I just shared with you
above. And you know what happened? We're
working with Disney now. And that's
where the whole thing flipped from being
a short-term perceived lose-win to a
long-term win-win. They got the small
private session that they asked for and
we got the opportunity to open the door
to something that is much more scalable.
That's what a good pre-game does. You
don't walk in hoping it works out. You
walk in understanding what matters to
both sides, where things might end up
wobbling in the conversation, and
because you do all of this preparation,
you have a much higher chance of
reaching the destination you're trying
to get to. For me specifically, I'd love
Disney to consider me to be the voice of
Mufasa in the future. Remember who you
are, Simba.
Is that all right? I thought it was
pretty good. Knowing my luck, they're
probably going to make me Pumbaa and
I'll be okay with that. So, that's what
you do before the conversation. But what
about when you're actually in the
conversation and somebody throws
something at you that you didn't see
coming and you start to get nervous? You
start to talk faster as a result of that
and then you start to ramble and then
you start talking in circles? That's
where most people lose themselves. So,
let me give you a framework that I use
in those moments that's going to help
you think on the spot. I call it PAR. P
A R. PAR. And the P stands for pause.
And I know this is hard because when
someone puts you on the spot, your
instinct is to start speaking
immediately and respond right away. You
feel like if you don't answer fast,
you're going to look unsure and
uncertain. But that's actually a trap.
Speaking fast makes you look nervous and
it makes you look like you didn't put
any thought into your response. People
value your words more when you pause and
think about your answer. So, pause. Give
yourself 3 to 5 seconds, 10 if you need
it. And if it's a longer pause, just
give them context you need a little more
time. Hey, do you mind just giving me a
moment to think through that really
thoroughly before I give give an answer?
That doesn't make you look weak, It
makes you look like someone who actually
thinks before they speak. Now, the A is
for ask. This one's massive because in
high-pressure conversations, the first
question people ask is often not the
real question they need answered.
There's often a question behind the
question. Chris Voss, the author of the
amazing book Never Split the Difference,
talks about using calibrated questions,
which are questions that begin with a
what or a how, which helps you uncover
the real question behind their question.
This keeps the other person talking, so
you get more information, so you have
more clarity, so you can give them the
answer they actually want. And the best
part? While you're asking these
questions, guess what you get more of?
You get more time to think. Let me give
you an example. Let's say you're in a
high-stakes meeting presenting social
media performance to a big client of
yours, and out of nowhere they ask,
"Ben, why aren't we growing more this
month?" Now, if you react too quickly,
you'll start defending your whole darn
strategy. But if you pause and then ask
a clarifying question, everything's
going to change in that conversation.
You might just say to them, after you've
paused,
"That's a fair question. How do you
define growing right now on social
media?" Then they're going to say,
"Well, our follower growth looks like
it's been trending downwards for the
last 2 months." Now they've identified
that growing is linked to follower
growth. Then comes the R in PA. It
stands for respond.
Now you respond, [music] but you're no
longer responding to the surface layer
question. You're responding to the real
question. Now that you have more clarity
on what they mean, you can respond with,
"Yes, follower growth has been down, but
if you look at revenue, it's actually
grown over the last 2 months, and
[music] that's because we've improved
our content targeting to reach more of
our ideal customers, resulting in more
money in your bank account, which,
correct me if I'm wrong, that is the
goal, right?" You see, if you had rushed
to answer that first question, you'd
have given the wrong answer to the wrong
question. That would make you look bad.
[music] But, by asking the calibrated
question, you were able to steer the
conversation in a direction that
actually makes you look good and speaks
to what the client actually cares about.
Money, money, [singing] money. So, the
framework again is simple. You first
pause, then you ask some calibrated
questions, and then you respond. But,
sometimes it's not just pa as I've
already slightly alluded to if you
noticed me using plurals before.
Sometimes it's
pas
because sometimes asking one calibrated
question isn't enough. Sometimes you
have to ask multiple. And, if you want
to learn more communication frameworks
just like this one, make sure you click
the link in the description or scan the
QR code that's on screen. I've recorded
a free 2-hour training that walks you
through my top three frameworks that I
use every single day to help me
structure my thinking before I speak so
that I don't ramble and I can get my
points across clearly. So, check it out
if you haven't already because it will
change the way you communicate for the
better. Now, underneath all of that,
this is a principle that I believe stops
anxiety in high-stakes situations. Panic
usually happens when you get attached to
one exact path instead of staying
anchored to the destination. So, the
real principle is this: know the
destination, be prepared, and be
extremely flexible with the pathway
there. And, I'll give you a personal
example. My dream car is a Ford F-150.
Why? Because I lived in America for 5
years, and while I was there, everybody
had one, and it was the coolest
adventure vehicle I'd ever seen. It was
love at first sight. And, up until the
recent years, this car was not available
in Australia. But, now it is.
And, I applied the lessons that I've
taught you in this video in the highest
stakes conversation I've ever had in my
life. It's my wife, Beywen. She's the
boss of the Shang household. So, going
into this conversation, I thought very
clearly about what I wanted and why.
Then I thought about what's in it for
her and the kids. And then I thought
about where the conversation could
potentially get rocky, everything that
I've taught you so far, and I could
already hear her saying, "We have too
many cars, Vinnie. Where's the money
going to come from? Why do we need
something so big and chunky?" So, I
anticipated all of those things before
the conversation even happened. Oh, I
was prepared. And so, when I had the
conversation, I focused the conversation
around the win-win. What's in it for
both us and the kids. Big boot space for
carrying supplies that we need for our
renovations. [music]
Epic towing power to tow the family
caravan safely. Because if it was just
me, I wouldn't care, but when you and
the kids are in the car, safety is
paramount. When we go to Costco, we can
put 2 months' worth of groceries in the
ute bed, so less grocery trips. It's a
big reminder of the chapter of us living
in the US and how much we loved it.
There are massage seats in the front
seats, so it makes long road trips more
comfortable for you and I. We have a car
now that can fit the kids' bikes,
kayaks, and scooters all at once. The
dogs can finally go on road trips with
us without pooping and vomiting and
destroying the leather seats in the
back. And finally, you know what they
say, happy husband, less money in the
bank account. But, don't forget the
first part, happy [music] husband. And
during that conversation, I watched her
face change. She smiled, then she also
looked angry at some parts, but mostly
it was smiles. And in the beginning, it
was a hard no, but as I started
explaining the family [music] benefits,
I watched her start to nod along. And
then guess what happened? We got the
truck! We got THE TRUCK! OH MY GOD, I
GOT THE F-150. I'M so happy, and it's in
black, too. How cool does it look? And
trust me, this doesn't just work in your
personal life, it works in your
professional life, too. And you're going
to be able to get more of the things you
want out of life if you remember. First,
go in with a win-win mindset. Second, do
the pregame and build the map before you
walk into the conversation. And third,
when the conversation gets a little bit
rocky, use the PA framework. And
finally, know the destination you want
to get to with clarity, but stay
flexible with the pathway there. Oh, and
make sure you go check out the free
2-hour training on communication
frameworks. If you want to get better at
communicating under pressure and stop
rambling, scan the QR code or click the
link in the description. I'll see you
inside that training.